hello everyone welcome back to the
channel i'm not wasting any time with an
introduction on this one i have the team
behind the new screen movie with me
right now matt tyler chad i've said it
to you off camera but again
congratulations and from the bottom of
my scream loving heart thank you
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you
so before we get into my my long list of
spoiler questions i just kind of want to
catch our viewers up with you guys i
know we did this a little bit for uh for
ready or not but got a couple more early
questions for you and matt and tyler i
wanted to start with you because back
then you told me that you used to work
at new line and it made me curious is
there anything you picked up at your
time over there that you found really
coming in handy in your later films
especially given new line's success and
how prolific they are in the horror
genre yeah aside from aside from like
picking up i think maybe the most
consequential thing which is each other
it's the friends we made along the way
the friends we made along the way like
that job introduced us and we both
worked at new line because of the work
that we loved the work that was coming
out of new line um but i mean our our
connection our working together wouldn't
exist if we if we didn't have those jobs
yeah and i i still remember my interview
at new line and you know like in any job
the first question they ask you is like
so why do you want to work here and i'll
never forget it i'm still friends with a
guy who interviewed me and he was like
why do you want to work here and my
answer was because you guys make my
favorite movies and he said name some
and the three that i named were pump up
the volume
friday and nightmare on elm street those
were like my like holy trinity and i was
like you guys did it
i got to be here
and then i just i just delivered mail
for 10 years
all right so now for the three of you as
a team here i know you guys have been
working together for i guess over a
decade now but do you remember the point
in your collaboration where the thought
went from
you know we're not just capable of
making shorts and internet videos but
this feels like the right team and right
assortment of people to be able to jump
to the next level and deliver you know
studio level features yeah i don't know
exactly at what point that happened but
i do know along the way that we we loved
the creative debate that we always had
amongst the three of us it was always
challenging each other to find better
better or more creative solutions any
problems that came came up and and
obviously when we were going forward
with like just say ready or not it you
know and we were eight how to do
everything we had to do for ready or not
in a very short amount of time we kind
of
really went back to the way that we
started like all right we have these
locations we have to go really fast we
have to run and gun we have to make sure
all you know all the actors are safe of
course but we also have to get every bit
going for it forward with it and i think
along the way we picked up a lot of
those things um and then even on screen
when we have like some of the best
department heads in the world working
around us there were still moments when
we had to go back and and one of the
easter eggs that we will talk about is
like the the michael myers shot in in
scream is actually matt with a knife
with tyler holding a camera and me
holding my iphone and lighting him up
from behind underneath and like we
couldn't get the clip real studio level
stuff recreate it
so you just had to recreate it from
scratch and there's just
three idiots in a dark room like holding
a camera and like oh this is this is the
way it gets made and this is why i think
that's a really interesting example
though because i would say the one thing
that's been the same for us from the
start is just there's this level of kind
of naive ambition where it's like
oh we have a cool idea let's just figure
out a way to do it and then that that
oftentimes for us meant like going to
crazy practical locations and and like
putting ourselves kind of through like
physical hell to capture the thing you
know we were also acting in and shooting
every you know all of our all of our old
stuff and and i think for us that that
feeling of like
when like inspiration and ambition kind
of intersect
and the level of excitement that there
is around that and it's like oh [ __ ] we
have to just figure out a way to do this
like it we will hate ourselves if we
don't if we don't achieve this thing and
then the fun is just figuring out a way
to do that with the resources you have
sometimes you have you know more
sometimes you have less and i think
that's really been the same for us from
from day one
i feel like that level of blind ambition
is absolutely necessary if you're gonna
get to work in this industry otherwise
it's just not an option for you yeah yes
i would say so
yeah
you've probably been asked this before
but i was surprised i didn't ask you
this during our last conversation
why why did you call your collective
radio silence
who's answering this
but that was a great silence
i felt like it was on purpose we try to
organize these so we don't all talk at
once and sometimes the opposite happens
um
uh you know what it is it's we when we
were just getting going
again kind of to your previous questions
like we always had ambitions of we were
like we want to like aim for the highest
thing and then see how far we get and
have fun along the way and hope for the
best and so you know once we started
doing some smaller stuff we'd have
meetings and that was really exciting
because we felt like we were getting our
foot in the door and we were like this
is so cool and then
for weeks after be like hey what
happened with that meeting
radio silence and we would say it all
the time to each other radio silence hey
we sent that script to so and so radio
silence and then when we got vhs and
descent well we didn't get vhs into
sundance when vhs got into sundance and
we were lucky enough to be uh writing
those coattails they brad miska bloody
disgusting was like well so who's the
director and who's coming to sundance
and again we were like well we all want
to go
let's just make up a name
and it was like three minutes of what
should we call it uh radio silence great
cool yeah so we're called radio silence
and that was it
i love that story so much it kind of
makes me appreciate it more and also
because just in general i really do love
talking about things like you know bumps
in the road how you overcame them and
how without those bumps in the road you
wouldn't be where you are today so
with that in mind i want to bring up
devil's due because i know that wasn't
received you know
super great with with like a loving
embrace or anything like that so
what would you say were some of the
biggest lessons you learned in terms of
film reception and moving on from it
having gone through that with devils do
and coming out on the other side i think
stronger than ever
yeah i i mean i i feel like our
reflection on that as that as that
project gets kind of further and further
in the rear view i mean i don't we
wouldn't i don't think we'd change
anything about it i feel like it we had
to go through that experience and it
feels like we went through that
experience which at times was like a
dream come true and and like more of an
opportunity than i think we ever managed
we ever thought we would have and then
other times it was really challenging
and i and i think what we can say is
that the people that we went through
that experience with are like still some
of our dearest closest friends and so
much of what was challenging about that
project for us was really i think we
were at
whether we understood it or not and i
think that we we sort of i think we
ultimately did in our hearts and
ultimately
were presented with an opportunity that
had so much momentum that we kind of
couldn't slow it down and make all of
the changes that we wanted to make was
we were sort of at the end of
of a sub genre in a lot of ways right
found footage was and i think it's back
kill the sub genre in short form
but honestly i feel like i feel like
chronicle did that really big
you know hollywood version of it and and
we were always going to be a little bit
in the shadow of that and and and i
think that that for us was really just
one of those challenges that we took it
really serious because we love that
format we think it's creatively it's
it's a really fun
really fun thing to dig into like the
rules of it are really interesting and
then think you know we think create a
lot of really fun kind of creative
debate but that was it it was just a
challenge it's a challenge to sustain a
found footage movie for for you know for
that amount of time um but the process
was incredible and i don't i don't think
we do i don't think we'd redo it and i
think there's a lot of us in that movie
we go we've rewatched it recently and
and it's funny and and we love those we
love zach and allison like their
performances are so great and um so yeah
i think i think it's we reflect on it
very very very
fondly
but i also feel like it's one of those
that had we made it maybe outside of
that system we would have also maybe
done some things a little bit
differently there wouldn't have been as
much pressure for it to like perform at
the at the same level and i don't know
it's it's it's a really interesting
moment in that specific format conflict
i'd also just add to that i think one of
the things that we've taken away from
that is because you know we got this you
know big break i mean we were gonna make
a studio movie and that was like the
most exciting thing in the world i
remember literally having the
conversation where we were like
we're getting the opportunity to make a
studio movie just take everything out of
it just to have had that experience as a
movie fan is just incredible
and then to have it not be embraced with
open arms as you so kindly put it
uh
it i think we i think it toughened us in
a lot of ways and it made because you
know our next movie after that was
southbound and it was like this nice
back to basics thing
and you know we basically we got put you
know directors jail is very real no
matter what anybody says we were making
another studio movie and we had to go
prove ourselves again and i think that i
think it
it helps us not take like this weekend
has been incredible scream opening and
being the number one movie in the world
is absolutely a dream come true and
beyond anything we expected but it also
helps us like
you know you got to take the good with
the bad and they i think it it just
makes us really
respect that and not but also not take
it too seriously like no yeah cool but
that's just as fleeting as the other
stuff you know because you have to show
up and make other stuff you have to keep
thinking
yeah yeah that's the most important
thing and obviously like we came up like
just making videos and giving them away
for free on youtube and being like all
right cool we'll do that and our very
first video like we get the review like
chad matt and rob is dumb dumb and dumb
and we could have just like packed it up
and said all right we're done but no we
just made another one and then we made
another one and and you're always going
to have those types of those types of
negative responses coming at you but you
the way you pick yourself up after those
is what really matters and and really
just get back to creative creating right
because if if creating and and making
things is in your dna then then that's
kind of all you want to do and and you
just take the bumps along the way and
you you kind of just get back up and get
right back at it
that's why i ask those questions all the
time you never know who else out there
needs to hear that from you guys in
order to be able to get over the bumps
themselves and i don't know maybe become
the next you guys you're right and
you're never you never know in the
moment what the outcome will be in the
future we we found out on ready or not
that the reason tripp and jamie hired us
to direct that movie is they loved
devils do
and they called the studio and asked
like how how were we to work with and
everyone that we worked with these
people that i that i told you we have
really close relationships with to this
day we're like they're incredible you
should absolutely work with them and we
never thought in a million years that
devils do would be responsible for us
getting to be involved in one of the
greatest projects i think will probably
ever work on ready or not and and so you
just never know without already
something is going to be yeah yeah and
end up making my scream exactly so it's
all on it's all on the continuum i think
the goal is to not ever like you were
saying chad did not ever let one thing
stop you from continuing on because you
never know what the ultimate outcome of
those experiences will be
what was the first reaction when jamie
and the team came to you guys and said
we want you involved in scream because
on the one hand like i'd be jumping for
joy my mind would be blown i'd be so
excited but i mean there's a significant
amount of pressure and if you don't make
due on fan
expectations i mean to be frank about it
it could be right back to director's
jail so at that point
was there anything at all on the table
that could have kept you from directing
this new screen movie uh yeah if the
script sucked but
it didn't it was it was incredible but
we went we went i remember we were on we
were on you know we basically spend
all of our waking time majority of the
day the phone together like even when
we're just they'll be like 10 minute
pauses where we just don't talk and
instead of just hanging a burrito
and uh i remember being on a call
together on the way over there and being
like what are we gonna do if it sucks
because we love these guys we love
everybody involved
it's one of our favorite franchises i
mean it's there's so much there's so
much on the line for us personally
and then there's also all the pressure
of and if we [ __ ] this up not only is
this incredibly embarrassing but we're
not making another movie like
we're not making another studio movie or
a movie at this level until we've built
ourselves up again southbound too and
we're going to make a sequel to south
carolina
i wouldn't mind that
we tried but neither would we but either
would we
but uh
but so i remember that conversation of
like how are we gonna uh how are we
gonna what are we gonna do if it's not
good and then
i mean luckily we didn't have to deal
with it but yeah to answer your question
it it it was a up until we read the
script it was a very real like
concern of ours
yeah and we managed our expectations i
remember thinking like we can't we can't
lower what we think the bar should be
for this for this script because we love
guy and jamie and we love the franchise
like if anything it's got to be it has
to hit at a level that it has to
surprise us
outside of our nervousness and how it
has to sort of consume that and get us
excited right like which was its own
sort of
obstacle i think our anxiety
was really
a huge obstacle and by the end of the
script reading the script we were all
just like
oh oh they got this
shock they're super talented super
talented
they made our jobs real easy
and then personal feelings on outside of
that go from obviously this is a very
manic business right so you do go from
moments of just utter relation to utter
terror as you're like taking on the
franchise but that's exactly why it's
the right project for us to do next
because we always say we want to make
movies where people think it's either an
eight or a nine or a one or two we don't
want the in between so we don't want the
like the out-of-bottling average movies
um like we want to take bold chances and
and
and really challenge ourselves that way
and that just it just really lined up
with that plus the script is really
great well we got devil's due for that
one in the two you know
that would say yeah
it was 17 percent on success
one more question before we get into
spoilers
so after seeing your movie and falling
in love with it it is really hard for me
not to be greedy and not to think about
what you guys want and just to sit here
and say i want to lock you guys into
making screen movies for the rest of
your lives but after making this 2022
scream
what what are your personal priorities
right now is there a desire to stick
with the franchise and continue on with
it or do you really want to continue to
explore different original ideas or
maybe another existing ip i mean i i
think i can say that we love both ideas
and i think we'll we want to pursue both
things we have a bunch of really fun
original things that we're working on
you know we we know that there's there's
you know been a conversation about ready
or not
um we we certainly know that guy and
jamie have have
amazing ideas about where scream could
go after this after this last one we
just want to be involved in all of it i
think once you've had an experience with
people that really changes you not only
creatively but like fills your heart up
and and fulfills you you know really in
in ways that i think we all
never thought we would be fulfilled um
you just want to replicate that as many
as many times as possible and so i know
we'll have a ton of really amazing stuff
with guy and jamie and william and paul
the project x you know team and
and then yeah we've also got i think
we've got a lot of really fun original
stuff coming up coming up as well so i
think a bit of a bit of all of it this
was a unique challenge and i think it
scratched a really an itch we don't know
we we had and i think it'll continue to
hitch so
hopefully there's more all of it yeah
bring it on i'll take anything and
everything
all right this is it i'm doing it the
one and only spoiler warning for scream
2022 please leave this video if you have
not seen the film push pause go see the
movie come back and then push play and
continue on right here is that that easy
all right usually i feel like i always
build up to the big stuff in these
interviews but i don't want to run the
risk of missing anything super important
so let's just start
eats return billy loomis is back what
were your initial thoughts on reading
that in the script because you know of
course it's fun to see a major character
or franchise icon return but you want to
be sure that that return is is
absolutely necessary
yeah i mean our in reading the script we
our our reaction that we hope audience
members have when he pops up was our
reaction reading the script we were all
just like what the [ __ ] and we also knew
that it was like
really going to push the guard rails out
on what you expect the screen movie to
do we also knew that that was 100 the
reason to do it and we also really loved
what that character coming back did for
our lead right for for sam played by
melissa barrera it
there's there's so much at work in that
in that billy you know father-daughter
relationship that's about legacy and
about the things that you inherit and
how you move on from them and what what
sort of pieces of of those legacies you
take with you which is obviously also
what the movie as a whole is about and
that baton pass from one one generation
to another and
and
and we also just for us like billy and
stu are just some like the most iconic
slasher villains of all time and to have
him pop up in the movie it feels like
such a moment where the movie is aware
of its lineage it's aware of its past
it's also aware of itself as a movie in
a fun way right it's sort of like hey
we're gonna have some fun we're gonna
like hollywood this thing up for for a
few moments um and then to also give
that character a bit of an arc right we
loved that the the villain that started
it all has a bit of a hero's return in a
weird way and is actually a part of of
sam of that character fully realizing
that she is that she's a but she's a
complete person it's just that a part of
herself
is is dark and is a thing that she would
like to keep hidden and and ultimately
has to come out for the movie to resolve
um we we just loved that turn for for
the character
that was actually a question that i had
so
i guess here's a really complicated
two-parter that's going to be a lot of
my questions because i have a lot of
them so i'm trying to cram them all in
but
is is the return of
billy something you see as serving the
franchise going forward and sam story
more going forward but then also how do
you view how he plays into this
particular film and what she goes
through it's like in the end are you
saying that it was it was necessary and
even good for her to tap into her inner
billy in order to kind of save the day
yeah i i mean i i definitely think that
in order to make sam
a true hero of our movie and actually to
carry the franchise forward a little bit
you do have to acknowledge her past and
what she comes from and and you know
like just the ability ability to
overcome any new challenge and if you
can overcome the fact that your father
was a serial killer and still do the
right thing at the end then you know you
need to to do that it's like i i think
and and that's kind of a message that we
all always want to get out into the
world like it doesn't matter what
happened like before it's like what you
do now and how you move your own story
forward and i think that that is the
embodiment of what sam is coming from
billy loomis and and and not having the
most pristine and you know
like
adolescence and teenage years and now
still trying to find herself and then
fighting for her family and her
relationship with her younger sister
tara um it's all part of it because
billy was so
selfish and so extreme to one end i
think the more she acknowledges that is
a part of her and a piece of her that
will always be there but also choosing
to go
um to to embrace family you know and
then also i mean like let out the fury
every now and then like we do at the end
like you need to have that you know you
need it you need to have that type of
tenacious fight in you um if you're
going to survive any of these movies
right right you just need to be able to
to when it comes down to it be
be the killer and make sure you're the
survivor um and now you get a fight with
with your family as you move forward um
and you know and billy will always be
there billy i think billy's now after
what we've established in this first one
billy is always a part of sam and sam
will always have a tether to billy and
and that's something she will always
struggle with
should there be a six
i have very high hopes uh how about
figuring out exactly how to show him is
what we see in the final film the
initial idea or did you ever consider
any other you know visual techniques or
styles in terms of incorporating billy
loomis
it's pretty similar to what we initially
talked about honestly we were like we
always wanted it to be just in the
mirror we were really conscious of in
this part came from the script we wanted
it to be make sure that she's never
scared of him she never reacts in like a
a fear way she is always kind of like
[ __ ] this guy again
um
and but what you see yeah it was always
supposed to be in the mirror we talked
about actually true romance a lot sorry
if i keep looking over here i have two
cats that want i think they want me to
feed them um i very much understand that
uh
but you know i think it was uh
we talked about true romance a lot in
the way that they kind of have that val
kilmer's elvis is sort of there but not
there and you feel him but you don't
have to see him all the time um
he never feels like a ghost which is
interesting he always is a hallucination
and not a ghost right
yeah we needed to make it really clear
that it wasn't a ghost because what we
didn't want to tiptoe into because again
we are not scream three haters but like
the maureen prescott thing we think
that's a great scene we hear it we hear
the issues with it but like it needed
it's what tyler was saying about it we
needed to make sure that you weren't oh
is this now a supernatural movie because
that's not the scream that i'm familiar
with um and at the end of the day we had
skeet for a day on set out in wilmington
and we just shot a bunch of stuff with
him with you know in front of a green
screen and melissa was there and they
did all the scenes
again for her and for the first time for
him and
you know i think it was one of those
things that we spent so much of the
previous year year and a half
talking about worrying about wondering
about how it would turn out and then
when we did it we were like
oh yeah that's it it's
it's kind of as written and it's it
works you know let's not mess it up i
don't think i've been on that wild of a
roller coaster in terms of my initial
reaction to seeing something and being
like whoa like i know about this and
then
you you prove your point at the end i
was very impressed by how that wound up
settling in you probably it's a little
jarring at first right
it's well it's definitely a little
jarring because well well actually
here's the other part of this question
it's a little jarring because like in my
mind billy is dead dead and he's been
dead for many films just in your minds
because i've had this conversation
personally i think too often stu is dead
dead dead right that tv fell on his head
and it killed him
yes
[Laughter]
this is a this is a debate that we have
had us in the writer guy music is and by
the way we are also stu defenders we got
to know matthew lillard over the course
of this and he is one of the greatest
people alive and so i i would love for
there to be more stew more story to tell
with with stu as with as with matthew
lillard um
but we need a what if scream what if
yeah exact yes right yeah i have a i
have a pitch for that
so i want a scream 2022 prequel of when
amber's family moved into stu's house
and she came to learn what happened
there and who he was and then maybe you
can incorporate matt's eat style in that
movie hey i like that that's a bad idea
it's like the others with matt lillard
yeah
okay
we should say perry then matt
is he in the party he does the voice of
flamethrower ghost face and he's at the
party he has a voice at the party
okay yeah
i love all these easter eggs um here's
the question you probably won't be able
to answer right now but do you have any
ideas uh who sam's mother is do we know
there's some fan theories floating
around out there we we love that there
is an off-screen story and that there's
more to be told about the carpenter
family she was she was written uh she
had a couple more scenes in the script
and it was really interesting when we
were when we were getting into
you know when the rubber was meeting the
road and we were really starting to prep
the movie it always felt like we were
letting a little too much air into the
into that
family unit that for a story that we
really wanted to be about those two
sisters anytime that it became sort of
larger than that and about a conflict
with mom and it just felt like we were
we're sort of muddying
the the specificity that we wanted to
achieve with these two these two sisters
needing to reconnect over this rift
caused by this this really dark secret
that is in one of their you know one of
their pasts and
and so we know there's like a really
cool christina carpenter story there
were little bits and pieces of it in in
one of the drafts and you know i
definitely hope it's something we can we
can explore more of down the line
as much as i want to see it as someone
who loves scream and also loves her
sister very much it was very exciting
seeing that kind of relationship done so
well in my favorite franchise so i'm
glad the focus was there
how this is more of a writing question i
get but how i guess but how about
picking the
killers was it always amber and richie
in every single draft of the script or
was there ever any you know toying
around and playing with other options
um yeah i think after talking to guy and
jamie i think that that it was always
the two amber and richie um i mean amber
is named after jamie's wife um her full
name is amber you know freeman and that
was her maiden name so he kind of just
like really leaned into his personal
references while writing about this this
killer um and then the same with richie
too and obviously when when we were
getting out into the casting phase of
everything we didn't want to send out
the entire ending so we would send out
the script that was only about you know
up until the the third act break which
which we very literally call out in our
movie and that was kind of we we sent up
right to right before that so people
didn't know when we were initially doing
our chemistry reads and stuff like that
who who the actual killer was um and
honestly the entire cast was just had a
blast with the game a little bit too um
while we were in like early prep at a
certain point you got to let them see
the rest of the pages as we prep for
these scenes and everything else too um
but they were all along for the ride and
they all all understood
the importance of keeping it a secret
from even their friends you know they
would tell them they were in a screen
movie but they wouldn't tell them what
their character was or what their role
was in it and and
they brought that reverence to it and
that that made that made the entire
experience that much more fun and and
the big revelations and the performances
that we did get on screen a lot more
exciting to watch
one of my most memorable moments in the
whole process was when we were reading
people we knew we were going to cast
jack and we got on a zoom he'd read he
had read a script where he didn't know
who the killer was and then we got on a
zoom with him and told him that he was
the killer and matt matt has the best
screen grab of the moment that
information is hitting jack quaid's
brain and he's just like
[ __ ] yeah yes
i know you guys or i think you guys had
alt scripts circulating with different
endings can you share any of those
unused endings
they were they weren't really they were
just different killers
you know and there were like some there
were changes but they were
they were the same basic idea but you
wouldn't be able to figure out what
everything was i think they changed some
of the motivation a little bit too but
guy and jamie would just kind of bust
them out for us as we needed them it was
pretty fun i think they had fun with it
they had fun they had a blast yeah did
you ever uh just for fun toy around with
making one of the original three a
killer
i don't think so right i mean i've never
heard guy or jamie talk about it it
never came up with us fair enough i mean
they wouldn't come on it's like yeah
exactly
i mean
i don't think anyone would have believed
you if you were trying to have that you
know figure it out on set game and then
one of them was in the mix
there needs to be an out of context like
meme out there with like
sid killing everybody because i think
that would be a pretty good horror movie
in and of itself the way she fires the
guns and her one-liners and everything
like that too that would be actually
pretty interesting to see that you
should make that meme chad what does
that mean bro
let's get it trending sydney as a psycho
that would be great yeah
you could probably make an all an alt
cut with the right assortment of clips
and the right music i'd probably watch
that
this is something that i love playing
with every single scream film so i need
to know if you guys know the definitive
answers here who committed what kill in
the movie we have a bit of a road map
that you know i think
with the exception of the opening which
you we think you could say was both of
them um it's mostly amber
she's [ __ ] she's [ __ ] crazy she's
crazy she's [ __ ] crazy but we sort of
and we had we had sort of we had
separate conversations with jack and and
uh and mikey and then we had a
conversation with them together and we
kind of built out the off-screen
relationship that you know was was
working uh
and motivating them and their their plan
and one of the things that we like to
talk about is that you know
jack that that the richie character
thinks that it was all his his idea it's
actually probably amber's idea that
she's kind of been leading from from
behind and and that we just love that
that makes richie like just one of the
most
pathetic characters at the end of the
day that he like doesn't really want to
get his hands dirty and do the gross
stuff he like wants to intellectualize
it all and amber's like [ __ ] it i'll
i'll break i'll break eggs
intellectualize things that aren't his
idea to begin with
yes
this might be me reading into it too
much but is there is there any specifics
to richie and to amber in terms of the
killing style it's like amber read to me
as like the stab happy one of the two
whenever it was like unnecessarily
violent and too much stabbing it was her
but maybe something like vince could
have been richie yeah the uh amber being
like the frenzied i mean she even does
it in the kitchen
it's yeah we agree with you there's a
little bit of a different style there
here's an amber question for you is her
demise a deliberate reference to once
upon a time in hollywood
we wish it was uh i mean because we love
that movie and we've watched it
collectively probably a hundred times
but
honestly it was just we loved mikey so
much and we wanted her so badly to be in
the movie and
it was just sort of either
lame or super serendipitous
that she was gonna get torched in this
one and
you know i mean i think we now it was it
was
the character amber was gonna get
burned alive and we really wanted mikey
madison to be in the movie
and then that happened
it is what it is but i think now we've
really come to embrace it as a fun sort
of like accidental nod
it's like one of the most disturbing
ways imaginable for the stars to align
but i absolutely love it i can't i hope
that mikey is getting asked that
question because what a ridiculous thing
to have two
yeah
bursting at the seams during the
non-spoiler junket to bring that up and
it was killing me not to
all right speaking of deaths man i've
got to ask this it still makes me sad to
think about it but
do do we dying yeah i don't know i've
got my own ideas for this but in your
own words why did dewey have to die
who's up on earth
yeah i mean
i'll i'll just get my two cents in real
quick it honestly is like something that
we had an emotional reaction to when we
read it and it was so emotional and it
was like such it was so gut-wrenching
when we read it we're like oh yes this
is the right choice this is exactly what
you need to feel
right now at this point in the movie and
and and also it's what it would be the
only thing that would bring sydney back
to woodsborough i think and and when you
approach it from that one too
you know you know and and everything
else that
dewey does in the movie he's always the
the
sydney carton for lack of a better i
don't know prototype of what he is he's
he's this hero that is always just
willing to sacrifice himself for
literally everyone else in the movie to
to to live on and and this being 11
years after the fourth one and like
trying to get the franchise to move
forward it's like this is another
sacrifice to the horror gods of of a
good man
that now you know the franchise can live
on a little bit and and the movie can be
what it is um and and you talk about
like
the emotionality of what scream is and
what it can be we go from
one of the you know
more brutal deaths of um
of our movie you know and and what leads
it right up into it is all the meta
awareness
um the scene with the youtube page and
with richie on the bed and talking about
stab eight and all that stuff so it's
one of the funnier scenes of the entire
movie and to have that go from one to
two
is just it's it's one of those it's one
of those moments where like oh wow we
get to do a lot of things in this movie
and and really experience a lot of
emotions and hopefully hopefully people
are supposed to be sad about this people
are supposed to have a new reverence for
this and and in the days after the movie
came out i think one of the biggest
things that and nicest things that
people said it was like they immediately
went back and watched the original um
just you could see dewey and the way the
way he started and kicked off everything
and and and that that just means a lot
he's he's a he's a beloved character in
in in movie history um one of the most
beloved and and and i think that's for
that exact reason is why it had to be
doing this one he's also unkillable
right like i think that's you know it's
not lost on us that him him being a a
survivor of so much brutality that you
know for the movie to for the movie to
show the audience that it was playing
for keeps and that there's no safety net
under under what you think the movie is
going to be which to us is honestly like
one of the most important things to
achieve with the screen movie is that it
is going to make you experience some
really difficult things and i think that
we all forget that like that is what was
so compelling about the opening of the
first movie that it hurts and you don't
like that feeling and and that it at the
same time completely has you hooked in
and and for us we had a similar feeling
reading that scene and then certainly
shooting it was like oh this is this is
a big deal and it's going to change it's
going to change the emotionality of the
movie in a way that that hopefully while
yeah it's super difficult it's also
gonna make everyone invest because they
want [ __ ] killers to get their
comeuppance and they cannot wait for
that to happen and that for us and we we
heard this during previews and all of
that it's like ooh that's when like the
engine of the movie kind of kicks into a
new gear where it's like
all right justice for dewey like now
it's about something else it's about
you know obviously finding out who the
murderers are and all of the fun who
done it stuff but it's also about like a
real justice in that moment and that for
us is like super super important part of
how how the movie feels and the shape of
it post post that difficult sequence
i'd also just say that you know david
had talked about
dewey thinking of himself as clint
eastwood and obviously we know dewey is
not
clint eastwood but you know he liked he
he he that's what he brought to the
characters that he he wanted to be that
guy you know and so there was something
special about i think
or not special but that we really tried
to put into his death scene where you
kind of finally give him that moment of
like
here he is he's doing the you know high
noon heroes walk he's going to do the
thing he's going to achieve it
and kind of let him go out like a hero
in a way that you know is
deserved isn't the right word but you
know what i mean like a
send him out you know in a funeral pyre
kind of thing like really go for it
and you know i think it was we just we
wanted to make sure that it didn't like
you know it wasn't like throwaway it
wasn't just like oh and then justifying
that was probably one of the most
difficult things for you to do with just
me as a viewer and the fact that you did
it is is still kind of blowing my mind
it's very difficult to let go of a
character like that yeah
i fee i feel like sad but an appropriate
send-off
that's that thank you for saying thank
mean i mean it um
mark
is mark kinkade right yes correct okay
just for fun
how do you imagine sydney and mark
reunited because there is no hint of a
reconnection in scream for
at some point after scream four he
probably called her and was like hey i
heard you went through it again
remember all that terrible [ __ ] we
experienced
yeah
you're talking about it niece
[Laughter]
fair enough i'll buy that uh
how did you wind up coming to include
the nod to kirby and does that mean she
could come back in the flesh in the
future
we reached out to hayden and i we we
always knew like it'd be such a fun
question to answer we we certainly know
that there is a
there is like a a real kind of critical
mass around the kirby the kirby thing
online and for our money she's one of
our favorite characters in the franchise
like we we just we love hayden's work in
that fourth movie and and thought it
would be really fun to like
provide some
some
conclusive you know some conclusive
evidence of her of her survival and we
reached out to her and at some point we
wanted to have her more involved at the
end of the day though you know for a
character that for us is as interesting
and as fun to watch as she is it didn't
make sense to like do something small
you know and it felt like it was a it
was a better way to service it for this
for this movie was to just have a a
light nod and we know the fans that that
are that care so dearly about that
character would pick up on it second you
see her face in that thumbnail i think
everyone's like well [ __ ] that there
there she is um
and you know i but i but i we love again
i think one of the fun things about the
universe of these movies is the
off-screen story you know mark mark and
sydney what's happened to kirby like all
of that stuff for us like that's that's
that's the fuel that kind of exists in
the tank once you leave the theater and
and we love we love thinking about you
know who these characters are
outside of the stories that we see on
screen i'll do it non-stop
bigger broader question here can you
share anything about deleted scenes we
have to look forward to is there
anything in particular you had a really
tough time cutting that you're glad
we'll be able to see down the line i
think everything we cut we did cut for
for the right reasons and we kept the
pacing of the movie going and we kept
the mystery going on i think there are a
lot of a lot of great outtakes in terms
of ad-libs that we would love to include
because honestly every every actor
involved had such they brought such
incredible charisma to every single
line delivery that we kind of wanted to
use them all i i mean just thinking of a
couple of like uh jack quaids at the
beginning and stuff like that like that
and and we just everybody was just so
into character that there were a lot of
things that ended up on the cutting room
floor that is just part of the process i
guess can i ask you for
one specific deleted scene and if it is
a deleted scene then can you tell me
about it yeah and by the way there are
some scenes that will appear you know
when the movie is released digitally um
that again as chad said like i think
it's always hard to lose it's always
hard to lose footage that you love but
at the end of the day i think you always
have to like think about what's best for
the project as a whole and you know
there was there was a great scene with
dewey at the bar that that was really
that was really fun and there was a
great judy dewey scene that we also
really loved but at the end of the day
you know it was the thing that sort of
happened as we were digging in into the
edit was really wanting to make sure
that it for as much as it felt like the
legacy cast
uh had a had a real pivotal role to play
in this movie that it also felt like the
new cast wasn't just disposable and for
us to do that you have to get the
audience to invest in in them in a
really specific way and you have to
spend time with those characters and you
have to know and calibrate really
specifically when you want to bring the
legacy cast in because they do have so
much gravitas right the second that like
dewey sid and gayle are in the movie
you're just like [ __ ] yeah
love those characters i want i want it
all i want all of that and and so that
balancing act for us was an interesting
challenge and a really fun part of
crafting that what what is ultimately
the movie great success in that respect
because when the movie ends obviously i
consider the idea of gail and sydney not
coming back and for the first time ever
i felt okay with that and i feel like
that just speaks to how powerful the new
ensemble you guys introduces so
job well done the one scene i wanted to
ask you about is there another scene
between uh liv and vince there is not
another scene
[Laughter]
no it's all right i'm a bad liar there
is somewhere in my heart
kyle was a trooper kyle kyle had
auditioned for some other parts that
just for you know a myriad of reasons
didn't work out and but kyle is so
[ __ ] great and classy and awesome and
he was like
i'll be anything you guys want me to do
i'm in and we're like
seriously like
we have this role but it's very small
but we wanted to feel big and he's like
[ __ ] yeah guys i'm on my way
it was like
you know i mean hats off to kyle for
coming and embracing that and i will say
like he he really i think he took that
character to the next level because that
character was
it was a you know he was a he was a lot
like he was on the page he was what kyle
did but i think kyle brought this like
um i'm trying to figure out how to say
this without
it's like a bravado like
mo it's like
yeah he had somebody in mind let's just
say he had somebody in mind that he was
basing
do it
fair enough and he gets red right hand
so he is a big winner right he gets red
right hand that's right all right i have
to let you go but i'm gonna end with one
big enormous selfish question and it's
going to put you guys on the spot
creatively
if i were in the market for a scream
tattoo
do you have any recommendations because
i can't think of anything that is
creative enough and uniquely my own
i think my mom would approve of that
she's really glad you're suggesting that
right now yeah
oh man i don't know that's a good one
that's a good question we've seen some
awesome ones by the way the the the
messages the incoming messages of scream
tattoos are really something else
i got one that
that would be a real swing but if you
pay attention
in the first this is in the first this
is the first screen uh
there is a piece of blood you guys
remember this when i like brought this
up
this is so dumb
there is the blood splatter on
sydney in the finale of the original
there is a little
thing on her face that looks just like a
heart it is it is like a perfect heart
and i i swear once you see it you can't
unsee it and i love it so much
that's my suggestion get a heart blood
tattoo on your face
i won't put it on my face but that is
like the type of little easter egg thing
that at least i could hide do you have
it anywhere do you have ideas do you
have like a list of things of options or
are you just like you want one you just
don't know what you just don't know what
it should be
i want something that no one else has my
jurassic park one was handwritten by
samuel l jackson so it's hard to top
that and i don't want to be the person
with like a handwritten quote from like
all of her favorite movies on her
but so i'm i feel like the only idea
i've come up with is some sort of
creative spin on a ghost face mask and i
have one artist who
will not get back to me but it's like if
i could find something like that
then i'm good we could probably like
reach out to lillard or
or you know i did get to do the tattoo
for you maybe it's who does the
tattooing that could be interesting
i'll warn you in advance when i asked
sam jackson i said to myself if it does
not look neat like i will not do it so
if you did that i would put this person
to the test if it does not look neat and
legit i will not tattoo it out to myself
well let us know if you come up with
anything i'm actually now i feel
invested
okay
i'll see this through with you all right
to be to be determined follow-up video
at some point in the future i have to
let you go i could i have like another
like two pages of questions here and i
won't dare do that to you right now well
we would love to
i'm gonna be sitting here revisiting
your movie probably over and over until
jurassic world dominion comes out so you
guys got a lot of time
perry it's been so fun congratulations
thank you thank you so much